hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well through his
detailed analyses of a number of
different approaches not just a moral
theory but two virtue ethics in
particular ranging throughout Western
history Alastair MacIntyre points out in
after virtue chapter 14 that there are
some competing rival accounts of the
virtues and that they're it's not simply
having different labels or recognizing
different virtues and vices the
understanding of what a virtue is is a
point of disagreement as well sometimes
not quite realized as such but MacIntyre
brings that out by providing these
differing accounts of the virtues so
then that raises another problem is
there any sort of unity that can be
brought to virtue ethics and MacIntyre
says that there is but it's going to be
a complex notion so he tells us that in
his account there's going to be three
stages in the logical development of the
concept of virtue which have to be
identified in order if the core
conception of a virtue is to be
understood and that each of these stages
has its own conceptual background what
are these three stages well he talks
about one that require
is an account of what I call a practice
which is what we're going to talk about
here the second and account of what I've
already characterized as the narrative
order of a single human life which is
going to talk about in the next chapter
and then the third and account of a good
deal fuller than I've given up to now
but what constitutes a moral tradition
talked about in the next chapter and the
chapters following that so he wants to
focus here just on this notion of
practice which turns out to be very
important for understanding the virtues
and he he tells us two things so he
points out that in the different
accounts of the virtues whether Homeric
or Aristotelian or others there are
well-defined human practices or he says
well marked areas of social practices in
with one would excel so for example
Achilles succeeds in the war or in games
Penelope in sustaining a household
giving counsel in the assembly nestor
does that if you know your Iliad and
Odyssey you understand the references
there and then he talks about Aristotle
as well and Aristotle has sort of a
broader more you know unified account
then then Homer does which MacIntyre is
largely endorsing and so practices turn
out to be in in large respect what the
virtues are going to bear upon he does
tell us that he wants to add two caveats
so we're gonna look at those then we're
gonna jump right into the analysis of
practices what are these two caveats he
says the first is to point out that I'm
not saying that virtues are only
exercised in the course of what I'm
calling practices so that's a very
important point virtue is closely
connected with practice and indeed in
order to make sense of the concept of
virtue and McIntyre's account practice
turns out to be essential but that
doesn't mean that virtues are only
exercised in the course of engaging in
practice
and you know why would that be the case
well consider some of the things that he
says about examples of practices
engaging in sports drills like throwing
a ball and catching it is not a practice
according to MacIntyre whereas the game
of football is a practice right and we
could say well what about a scrimmage
then well you know scrimmage would
actually fall on on this side even
though it's not a game played for
records or anything like that it could
be understood as an integral part of the
playing football later on and indeed the
throwing the ball back and forth or
engaging in any other sorts of drills
those are practice seeing but those are
not practices the way MacIntyre calls it
and virtue could apply to to any of
those you know you could throw a ball
back and forth in a bullying way you
know throw it to somebody and say hey
butterfingers you suck well you know
that that would be unvirtuous in some
respect the other thing that he says is
that and this is very important to get
across so I want to I want to super
stress this I want to warn I will be
using the word practice in a specially
defined way which does not completely
agree with current ordinary usage
including my own previous use of the
term so MacIntyre is making practice
into a technical term of virtue ethics
now he's not saying that it's totally
disconnected from our ordinary usage or
even usage in in philosophy he's just
saying we got to be careful here here's
what I have in mind by a practice so
he's going to give us the definition
here this will be refined in later
literature but we're only gonna stick
with what he's saying and after virtue
assuming that one is only looking at
this account so what is a practice
here's the how it runs in the text and
we're going to come back to each of
these points in time by a practice I am
going to mean any coherent and complex
form of socially established cooperative
human activity through which goods
internal
that form of activity are realized in
the course of trying to achieve those
standards of excellence which are
appropriate to and partially definitive
of that form of activity with the result
that human powers to achieve excellence
and human conceptions of the ends and
goods involved are systematically
extended so that is quite a mouthful
that's quite a paragraph in a single
sentence worthy indeed of Augustine or
Cicero but it encapsulate everything
that McIntyre wants this notion to
include so let's take a look at each of
these parts and then we're going to take
a look at the the internal goods a
little bit more closely because he
provides us with a fuller account of
that so a coherent and complex form of
socially established cooperative human
activity so activity as such is not what
a practice is not everything is going to
be a practice it's got to be some
socially established activity and the
bar is not particularly high for that
that could include the private languages
of twins you know or little traditions
that are carried out within a family
that are actually meaningful because
there you've got something that is
socially established but notice what
else he says coherent complex not
everything will will function as a
practice in that respect either so idly
think about the thing that you see in
old movies when people are bored and
sitting in a hotel room they've got a
hat the private eyes do this and they're
throwing cards from a deck of cards into
the hat right isn't that a MacIntyre in
practice I don't think he would say that
it is even though it is socially
established and that it becomes a trope
it's it's you know is it coherence I
suppose there's a certain coherence to
it it's not complex and it could fit
into a larger practice of say
entertaining oneself but I don't think
that it's a practice by itself so
complex
coherent cooperative is another thing
that doesn't mean that it rules out
competition so let's think for example
of one of the the cases that he brings
up the game of football does involve
competition right you don't have a game
if you don't have competing teams and
indeed you may even have competition
within the same team you know for
example and we're talking about American
football here the wide receivers there
could be five to six of them on a given
team and they will compete with each
other to see who can actually get the
most time on the field who can be the
first string who can get the ball passed
to them the most often so they're not
just competing against the opposite team
but perhaps against their own teammates
but all of this in a larger sense is
cooperative there is a set of rules
governing it you can't just do anything
that you like and if you watch American
football you know for example that well
in the past helmet to helmet contact and
tackling somebody was not only a ok but
by some coaches actually encouraged now
that we know that concussions result
from that and other injuries
you can't even lead with a with a helmet
in tackling somebody because you might
damage the the rest of their body that's
not allowed and players do violate that
and then those players are penalized and
indeed their team is penalized another
thing that shows that it's cooperative
so activity internal goods we're going
to come to that in a moment
suffice it to say internal goods are
goods that are internal to the practice
of that activity and so they can't be
realized in other ways except in certain
other cases then we have standards of
excellence and McIntyre is going to
discuss this at considerable length this
is going to turn out to be very
important there are standards of
excellence to anything that is going to
count as a practice for McIntyre so even
fishing you know like cooperative
fishing on a fishing boat there are some
standards there you can't do it in
whatever way you want you know you can't
say well today we're not going to put
the nets out for the fish we're just
going to dress up in the nets
and pretend that we're fish and flop
around on the deck no no you could do
that but that is violating the standards
of excellence right and you know tearing
the Nets would probably be a problem you
know because you didn't repair them
properly or scrutinize them so there are
standards of excellence involved
McIntyre by the way loves the example of
fishing boats and he uses it quite a bit
in after virtue and in other things so
that is a key idea and the standards of
excellence he says are appropriate to
and partially definitive of that form of
activity so they're not just any
standards of excellence applied from on
high they are appropriate to that kind
of activity and he says they are
partially definitive of that form of
activity they tell you what it is to do
that practice so McIntyre would say with
with some of the things that we're gonna
come as practices you can't just do
whatever you like and claim that you're
doing that practice so let's go on
there's a longer thing that he talks
about here he says that with the result
that human powers to achieve excellence
and human conceptions of the ends and
goods involved are systematically
extended so we have two key things there
that are closely connected together
human powers capacities abilities to
achieve excellence that could involve
like learning a skill and human
conceptions of the ends and goods
involved are systematically extended so
the skill the the means whatever it
happens to be that is connected to some
sort of end or good and both of these
are not simply taken for granted as
static once and for all
they are being systematically extended
over the course of the practice this may
not happen in every single moment it may
not happen even in any particular era
but if we look at practices over time
they are getting more and more full they
are getting better
MacIntyre says they can also go into
decline as well
and the one of the examples that we have
will illustrate that so each of these is
important let's look now at internal
goods what does he mean by internal
goods
he says there's two kinds of goods
achieved in a practice on the one hand
there are goods externally and
contingently attached to that practice
and to other practices by the accidents
of social circumstances so you know in
the case of the the child who he bribes
in to playing chess candy kids love
candy right in the case of adults goods
such as prestige status and money and he
says there's always alternative ways for
achieving such Goods and their
achievement is never to be had only by
engaging in a particular kind of
practice so if I'm engaging in the
practice of medicine and I'm doing so to
be a big-shot or to have a you know
place in the country club or to make a
ton of money or to dominate people and
boss them around you don't have to go
into medicine to do those sorts of
things as a matter of fact if you focus
too much on those sorts of things those
external goods it's debatable whether
they're bossing people around is such as
external good but we could think of it
as power or authority you're not going
to be a good doctor this and this goes
by the way all the way back to Plato's
Republic in which there's a wonderful
discussion in Republic book one of the
practitioner and the craft or the type
of knowledge that they're involved in
and whether the goal of that is to
exercise authority or to make money or
whether it's to benefit the thing of the
craft
for example medicine if you're not
actually helping patients something went
wrong there right if you're not
producing health which is the
distinctive good of medicine
you could also say you know
understanding the human body things
along those lines which might be a
benefit both to the doctor and to the
patient internal goods are different
they can as he says only be realized in
the course of their practice so he says
we can specify them in
terms of that practice or other things
of that sort and by means of example
from those sorts of practices so you can
only get the goods internal for example
to chess by actually playing chess or
engaging in similar practices great
example of this is so you you you know
you like chests and you become very good
at it you are developing within that
practice you're developing both the
capacities you know of thinking several
moves ahead strategic thinking and
you're also developing the distinctive
goods involved in that which could be
like fair play well you can transfer
that to other games other games some
other games may not be particularly good
candidates I would say checkers probably
not that much backgammon again probably
not that much because chance intervenes
so so much maybe there are a different
class go on the other hand you could
move from chess to go and it would take
you know some adjustment but you'd be
using a lot of the same sort of
capacities and developing the same sorts
of internal goods so these these
internal goods are quite often
excellences that can only be realized
within that practice you can't cheat
your way there another prime example of
this that MacIntyre doesn't talk about
in this chapter but fits in very well
and he talks about elsewhere is
practicing a musical instruments to be
able to play for example the violin
which requires a considerable investment
of time if any of you have ever heard a
child first learn adults first learning
violin it sounds god-awful doesn't it
for quite a time and there's a lot of
refinement and skill that's needed and
there are little cheats that you can do
like you know you can put something
that's like a fretboard on the thing so
you know where to put your fingers
sooner or later you got to take those
off and you can't as we would say in
another form of music fake the funk you
can only do that at a very beginner
level and you can't do that as we
move on up so internal Goods can only be
realized within that or similar
practices they are different from
external goods the other thing that he
says that's particularly important here
is that internal Goods can actually only
be identified or recognized by the
experience of participating in the
practice in question those who lack the
relevant experience are incompetent
thereby as judges of internal goods now
we would want to understand this rather
broadly does that mean that I cannot
actually understand the goods of playing
American football unless you happen to
have played American football say you
know on your own as kids on the
playground or in gym class or actually
on a team I don't think we want to go
quite so far because perhaps spectating
is also part of the the practice in this
case in the my own case of course I
could say that I I do have enough
experience in playing American football
to recognize what's going on you know
because I did that same thing with
soccer or fencing or you know various
martial arts or a track shot would but I
also benefited from having had a very
extensive physical and curriculum which
younger right not everybody could could
say that sort of thing and when we look
at other examples we may have trouble
with this as well but this is what
McIntyre is saying that at least to some
degree we can only recognize and
identify these Goods through engaging in
the practice and this is something quite
true beginners often don't really
understand what the point of what
they're doing is the big point they they
get caught on what we might call
intermediary ends and they get very
obsessed with those and they don't see
the bigger picture and now let's talk
for a brief moment about some of the
examples of practices that MacIntyre
talks about he loves the example of
chest and he gives us the example of a
child who you're trying to teach chess
much of the you know quite similar to
the experience that
I had with my grandfather except I
wasn't getting candy in the process so
you bribe a kid to play chess and and
you give them candy whether they win or
lose and then you give them more candy
if they do win so now they've got an
incentive to win are they going to play
fair or are they going to cheat you know
sometimes when my grandpa would be
thinking about the move I'd like make
noise to distract him that would be a
form of cheating right and if you really
want to beat somebody in chess and win
fair and square as we say you can't do
that sort of thing as a matter of fact
you have to focus on getting better and
better at the game itself so I read
books and I never got particularly good
but I did play a good bit of chess in in
elementary and middle and high school I
had a friend who used to beat me all the
time because he was it was a much better
chess player than I was a greater
strategic thinker and eventually the
child recognizes that if they want to
get good at chess it can't be for candy
it can't be just for winning they can't
cheat they have to accept the standards
of excellence of the practice so that's
a good one another one that he brings
out that he develops over the course of
a page or so portrait painting he says
that the successful portrait painter is
able to achieve many goods which are in
the sense just to find external to the
practice of portrait painting fame well
social status even a measure of power
and influence at courts but those are
not to be confused with the goods that
are internal to the practice what are
the goods internal to the practice he
says that the internal goods are those
which result from an extended attempt to
show how Vidkun Stein's dictum the human
body is the best picture of the human
soul might be made to become true by
teaching us to regard the picture on our
wall as the object itself in a quite new
way and then he says that you know what
is misleading about Vic in Stein's
dictum is the truth in George Orwell's
thesis at 50 everyone has the face he
deserves but then he says this what
painters from Giotto to Rembrandt
learned to show was how the
saij may be revealed as the face that
the subject of a portrait deserves this
is by the way is why we could have a
book like the portrait of gray right
blanking on his name by Oscar Wilde
the notion is that when you're actually
painting the physiognomies something
more than just the material is coming
through and you're depicting it in a
medium that is a set of internal goods a
certain kind of truth is available there
and cheaters or people who don't develop
their talents adequately are not going
to be able to realize that good and then
McIntyre has this long discussion about
what's going on from medieval paintings
of icons to naturalism to you know later
French painting of aristocratic faces in
the 19th century what's going on in
Rembrandt and he says that there is
first of all the excellence of the
products both the excellence in
performance by the painters and that of
each portrait itself so that excellence
that is a an internal good and then he
says that we can also you know frame
this in other ways as well
and there can be rise and decline in
this tradition he also says that what
the artist discovers within the pursuit
of excellence in portrait painting is
the good of a certain kind of life that
life may not constitute the whole of
life for someone who is a painter by a
long way or it may for a period god gone
like absorb him at the expense of
everything else but it is the painters
living out of a greater or lesser part
of his life as a painter that is the
second kind of internal good to painting
so we have the production product itself
and then we have a certain kind of life
that's being realized in it that's
that's something that's there in
portrait painting we've talked quite a
bit about football as a game so I'm
going to skip over that MacIntyre also
talks about farming as a practice as
well and he says that simply paint
planting turnips I don't know if you're
in the turnip site as if I was going to
plant just one crop it certainly
wouldn't be that but just planting one
crop is
not actually farming there are a whole
set of things that go into the the the
practice of farming and many people are
engaged in that a good you know question
to ask ourselves would agribusiness
actually be a practice from act
McIntyre's perspective probably not
probably it would it would not qualify
as a practice he also talks about
architecture and here he says something
kind of interesting maybe a little bit
debatable I leave this to you to think
about it he says that bricklaying is not
a practice and I'm not entirely sold on
that because they have so many friends
and family in the trades I think about
my uncle Scott who is a master drywaller
before he eventually became an
ironworker
and some of the things that he was able
to do with drywall which were just
amazing I think that could actually
qualify as a practice and I would have
conversations with him and he would talk
with satisfaction of finding the
solution to this particular problem
posed by the need to curve this in such
in such a way I would say that could
probably qualify as a practice but even
more so what McIntyre is calling
architecture is a practice there's all
these other you know things that are
brought under it by the way the word
architect tone in Greek that we get
architect from means master builder the
person who has the you know the RK the
rule the determination of all of the
other skills beneath them and so they
are the one who have the master plan and
they oversee the process so a contractor
or a builder would also be engaged in
practices like that and there are some
determinate internal goods to that when
it's done just for money just for
prestige just to you know be the first
in the market not a practice or in a
practice that's not being done well you
could say then finally McIntyre says
something much more general about making
and sustaining communities
he says that in the ancient and medieval
worlds the creation and sustaining of
human communities of households cities
nations is generally taken to be a
practice in the sense in which I've
defined it so is the range so the range
of practices is going to be quite wide
arts sciences games politics in the
Aristotelian sense the making and
sustaining of family life all fall under
the concept so we see that this is quite
a robust and complex notion and again I
want to reiterate internal goods
absolutely central to two practices so
our standards of excellence so is the
idea that human conceptions of the ends
and and goods as well as the capacities
or means to develop them are
systematically extended by engaging in
the practice and this is part of what
learning a practice does for an
individual and we can talk about doing
this also as a continual process by
which a practice goes on as a part of a
tradition
you